nos piden que graphic hemos la imagen
del punto a mediante una reflexión a
partir del eje l aquí tenemos lgl y
queremos graficar la imagen del punto a
mediante una reflexión a partir de ese
eje entonces una forma de pensarlo es
que el punto a se encuentra exactamente
a 1234 unidades hacia la derecha de l
así que su reflexión estará cuatro
unidades hacia la izquierda de l
vamos a ver 1234 esta es la imagen del
punto a podemos decir que es el punto a
prima si hacen este ejercicio en khan
academy simplemente pueden dar clic y
les aparecerá el punto entonces esta es
la reflexión del punto
a partir del eje el hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí nos piden que grafique mos la
imagen del punto b mediante una
reflexión a partir del eje x
este es el punto b y vamos a reflejarlo
a partir del eje x entonces si pasamos
del punto b al eje x podemos ver que se
encuentra exactamente a 5 unidades
debajo del eje x 1 2 3 4 5 por lo que si
queremos reflejar ese punto al otro lado
del eje x ya sabemos que se encuentra a
5 unidades por encima del eje x 1 2 3 4
5 aquí se encuentra la imagen y podemos
indicar la como b prima reflejamos este
punto mediante el eje x hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí nos dicen que el punto se
prima es la imagen de c que se encuentra
en las coordenadas menos cuatro menos
dos mediante una reflexión a partir del
eje y cuáles son las coordenadas de s
prima 11 en el vídeo y vean si pueden
resolverlo por su cuenta
bueno hay varias formas en las que
podemos resolverlo y no hace daño hacer
un diagrama
rápidamente vamos a ver aquí tenemos el
eje x y este es nuestro eje y y nos
dicen que originalmente el punto se
encuentra en menos cuatro coma menos dos
entonces podemos ponerlo así menos 4 - 2
este es el punto ce y queremos
reflejarlo sobre el eje y vamos a
reflejarlo sobre este eje y que estoy
resaltando de color rosa ahora aquí
podemos ver que el punto ce se encuentra
cuatro unidades a la izquierda del eje y
por lo que su reflejo estará cuatro
unidades a la derecha del eje y así que
en lugar de cuatro hacia la izquierda
vamos a movernos cuatro unidades hacia
la derecha eso es más cuatro entonces en
dónde se encuentra se prima nuestra se
prima se encuentra justo aquí y cuáles
son sus coordenadas bueno tiene que
tener la misma coordenada y por lo que
la coordenada que desee prima es menos
dos pero
cuál es su coordenada x bien pues en
lugar de menos 4 al pasar al otro lado
del eje y ahora la coordenada x es más 4
por lo tanto aquí las coordenadas son 4
menos 24 coma menos 2 y tal vez ustedes
hayan podido hacer todo esto mentalmente
aunque para mí la verdad es que si lo
intento mentalmente visualizo esto en mi
cabeza
- 4 - 2 se encuentra en el tercer
cuadrante y si lo volteó al otro lado
del eje y la coordenada lleno cambia
pero la coordenada x será opuesta y el
punto ahora estará en el cuarto
cuadrante y eso es exactamente lo que
pasó la coordenada ya no cambio pero en
el caso de la coordenada x como pasamos
al otro lado de y es lo contrario a
menos 4 es 4 positivo con esto
terminamos nos vemos en otro vídeo